tada
today we're going to talk about about
Bitcoin not just the block not
blockchain in general but Bitcoin
specifically and so these slides are
inspired by Aviv's all from muji from
whom i stole some paintings pictures a
but he knows about it so it's ok so ok
so let's just start it so we'll talk
about what is Bitcoin what is the
blockchain how does it work and how what
can we do with that data science on
Bitcoin and the blockchain and also
about some some ways that we can like
sign the Python packages and stuff that
will help you if you want to start
yourself ok so what is a Bitcoin it's a
decentralized digital currency so we'll
talk a little bit about what this means
but then mainly there's no bank there's
no government there's no one controlling
the money I like in check-ins or in
dollars where the US bank controls the
money here nobody controls the money
nobody prints the money no one can just
print bitcoins like no centralized
government and it was invented by
Satoshi Nakamoto it's in their quotes
because because nobody knows who Satoshi
Nakamoto is there is a very poor
Japanese guy who whose life has been
ruined by this but he's not Satoshi
Nakamoto there's theories but nobody
still knows who he is and it was
launched in 2009 so Bitcoin promises to
be pseudo anonymous not anonymous we'll
talk about the difference between this a
the transfers are irreversible so if I
paid someone money with bitcoin and I
didn't get my money's worth I can't like
call the bank or the credit company and
complain that I didn't get to start it
like the money's gone there is a fixed
amount of bitcoins that can be mined
we'll talk about mining and what that is
and so but there's a I think 26 million
is the top amount you can get to
bitcoins can't be seized by the
government we'll talk about this because
there's been president that they can but
the technologically it can't and it can
by by by past ovulation censorship in
certain countries okay so how does how
the money transactions work today if I
want to transfer a one dollar to someone
else or blue once the terms red wants to
transfer one dollar to blue so red says
to the bank transfer $1 the bank goes to
the database or the books and checks if
red does have one dollar if so it
changes the books and moves one dollar
from red to blue and says to blue now
you have an extra dollar nobody sees
this money but the transfer is accepted
because the someone vouchers for it and
Bank vouchers for it
okay so we all agree that blue has one
dollar and red has one dollar less and
so how do we do this say with a digital
decentralized currency we have no Bank
now okay so red still wants to transfer
one Bitcoin to blue so if this was our
were a cash transaction blue would just
a red would give blue one coin and
nobody would have to know about this but
because it's a digital currency so
there's no Bank and red transfers to
blue and nobody hears about it so it's
like it didn't happen so we can't have
that but there is no Bank so what the
solution in bitcoin is that red sends
out the request to everyone in the
network everyone if we're all Bitcoin
users everybody sees this request
everybody individually updates their
books saying that red now has one less
dollar or Bitcoin and blue has one more
Bitcoin and everybody so everybody
checks their books to see if this is
possible and if so that transfers is
approved and now blue has one more
Bitcoin so this is a problem as you can
see because everybody has to keep the
books everybody has to keep their own
copy over the database and update it
individually it has to
think up so this is a problem the
blockchain is this database this is what
everybody keeps so if you are a Bitcoin
user you keep on your laptop or desktop
or phone you are supposed to keep the
entire blockchain the right now it's
around 300 gigabytes of data so and it
there's a like millions of users so you
can understand the extent of this a
wasted storage but okay so and what is
the blockchain the blockchain is
basically a linked list but it's a smart
linked list it's what called the merkel
to your hash tree so it's composed of
blocks every ten minutes a block is
created in the system and all
transactions that occurred within these
ten minutes will go into the new block
and every block is Al is labeled with a
crypto cryptographic hash of the
previous block okay so we can't just
like I can't create a new block and
insert it anywhere in the middle because
there the cryptographic hash has to
match and this is created within the
system and the hash changes the hash
function and it's a kind of randomized
so you can't mess with it okay so this
is basically how it works so now a new
block is created and all the new
transactions will go here and ok and
we'll talk about how this happens so how
how is the block created in Bitcoin hey
everybody
every Bitcoin user keeps a copy of the
blockchain and also runs the code the
core code okay what this does is
basically it tries to solve a
cryptographic puzzle which differs in
difficulty the long as time goes on the
difficulty increases and if you're lucky
enough to solve this puzzle then you get
a new block this is what's called mining
so you get a new block and you mine
bitcoins today if you get a new block
and you mind you new bitcoins you get 25
bitcoins for this and you are now the
creator of the block and everybody sent
you've seen all the transactions that
everybody's tried to send over in the
last 10 minutes you pick the ones that
pay you the highest fee and you insert
them into your block and you send it out
to everybody in every
puts this new block at the end of their
chain so this is how it works and this a
cryptographic puzzle you basically how
it can think about it as having to guess
a very very long binary stream so this
is so this is how it works and I can
trade the difficulty is that they set at
approximately every 10 minutes there's a
new block created and this is of course
in expectation so what is a Bitcoin
transaction if a transaction in Bitcoin
are a little more complicated than
regular transactions because if I want
to I have ten bitcoins I will just want
to send to someone one Bitcoin I have to
send all of my bitcoins and split them
into two one I will send to whoever I
want to transfer money to and nine I
will transfer back to myself maybe to a
different account of mine but they have
to send everything out so there's in
multiple inputs and multiple outputs
possible for every single transaction
which is important because they will
talk about it in the data science so
this is a what the blockchain looks like
parsed
I ran some code to parse it and so you
see this is a blocker this is a first
block in the blockchain the ever okay so
the previous hash is zero and this is
the American root it doesn't matter and
this is a new transaction we can see
there's inputs and outputs so this is a
very basic transaction because there
were no Bitcoin users at that point in
time but we'll see a this is a
transaction from like years ago
approximately and now we have multiple
inputs in the same transaction I think
there were like a hundred inputs for
this transaction and one output okay so
this was this is someone
that was like doing something a little
bit fishy right moving money around the
million inputs to into one transaction
this is like not a regular transaction
but this happens a lot in the blockchain
so okay so whenever a block is they
created someone collects if you pay a
fee for your transaction and if the
transactions are adopted according to
highest fee and and there's okay we can
talk a little bit about what happens if
two blocks are created simultaneously
because this is a problem right a block
what if I have a lot of computational
power and I disconnect my computers from
the internet and I start mining and
mining and mining I run my code and I
get a new block and now I want to double
spend my money which means basically I
want to spend one Bitcoin and make it
into two bitcoins so what can I do I can
create a transaction in my block that I
send all of my money to myself and then
I can sell tell someone else that I sent
him my Bitcoin okay I can like see I can
tell him okay look at this transaction
I'm transferring my Bitcoin to you and
then immediately after he sends his
goods in return for my money i propagate
my already mined block so now my block
complete competes with this innocent
block and both her and I and maybe I can
like I cannot pay for my goods my block
takes so in order for this not to happen
the protocol works according to a
longest chain rule which means that if
they're like if I sent my block out and
already two or three blocks were created
in the other chain that everybody else
sees then the longer chain wins and
there is a the promise that Satoshi
wrote in his paper that if no one
controls more than 50% of bit code
between a computational power then this
can't happen
x-play it exponentially the chance of
you doing this exponentially decays in
time if you don't control 50% of the
network this is false okay
this was disproved and there are
examples of people you if you control
around 34% of the network you can do
things like this and this has happened
in the past okay
if you propagated your block and it was
adopted by everyone and nobody still has
a longest chain then you win so you have
to you play on the variance of this if
you have a lot of computational power
you control the variance more and
smaller players this is what's called
The Selfish minor tech okay so if you
really want to know that your money your
transfer is confirmed you really go to
bitcoins for your good you better wait a
few blocks until this happens because
the longer you wait the more chances are
that the lower the chance that someone
can steal your money but the block is
created every 10 minutes so this means
you maybe have to wait in half an hour
an hour to confer you confirm your
Trinette transaction which is a lot of
time so this is not really visible in
like real life transactions we do and
the truth is nobody really uses bitcoins
for real transactions today so it's not
effective that's money today hey okay
oh this talked about a little bit so
it's true that a ok it's a more mining
power you have the more chances you have
way of the mining block and the bigger
your mining pool is them you control the
variance more because if you're a small
player it's written it in expectation
you have to wait the same amount of time
but it's not true like the variance is
very high so being a part of a large
pool enables you to do more ok so this
is how the mining pools are split this
is I took to this room not change like
month ago so you can see the largest
pool is 16% in 2014 there was a pool
that controlled a little over 30 percent
so 34 it can happen like this 3 this is
mining pools now we'll talk a little bit
about Bitcoin anonymity so the way
Bitcoin works is that everybody has a
publicly in the private key and
transactions as you see them in the
blockchain you can only see the public
key right you saw when we looked at the
parsed the blockchain you saw this like
hashes and public keys you didn't see
names all right so basically nobody
knows how to connect your publicly to
your private key except you and your
wallet specifically this is very nice
like for if you want to I don't know buy
and sell drugs or children or I don't
know weapons or whatever people do with
their Bitcoin hey no nobody goes to the
grocery store okay so and you can
generate as many addresses as you want
so you can have as many public keys as
you want and this is it becomes
increasingly hard to trace after a while
like but you can do it so you can
actually
oh and there's of course people use
additional services like tor and the
bottom line is that everybody can see
every transaction you can maybe know
what who it is that the district made
this transaction but you know who you
know about every transaction for since
the beginning of time with Bitcoin so
this is like goldmine for data
scientists right okay so what can we do
okay so in 2013 I think edition million
delete one from Weitzman Institute it
had a very nice idea I think it's like a
very nobody thought of it but it's not a
very outer idea they said create a graph
of Bitcoin transactions parse the
blockchain into a graph of transactions
then group together transactions with
multiple inputs using union-find or
something like this which is a it makes
sense like if two people are
transferring money to the same
transaction you can you can usually
assume that there's the same entity and
this is you produce something called the
entity graph and you can also use
clustering methods to see because the
its are likely like the drug dealers and
the
I don't know where what pornographers
they talk to each other that much so you
can see a cluster of each kind of
criminal I think in Bitcoin pretty
easily and also you know a lot of
information you like because some people
like advertised like money launderers
advertise themselves like and of course
exchanges you can know who they are so
you can like eliminate of a lot of noise
and do a lot with this and this is
actually something that a Shamir and one
already did in 2014 so it was a lot
smaller at the time now it's harder to
do because it's just computation it's
not that hard like we managed to do this
with I think 500g Gorham which this is a
very good use of university resources
yeah so we'll see a positive and
negative example of this so a positive
one is actually when the FBI used this
method methods to way to dismantle the
Silk Road the original Silk Road if
nobody okay so Silk Road there if you
have ever gone into the dark web or like
looked around like I did in 2010 I think
you immediately get to the Silk Road
which is like basically eBay for
criminals you can buy drugs you can buy
weapons you can buy anything you want
and they of course using Bitcoin so
nobody can ever find out so there and
there was a guy controlling the guy that
founded the Silk Road called himself
Dread Pirate Roberts which is funny
thing and so and the FBI had enough of
this so they were like we're going to
find this guy later so they spent a lot
of resources and they used methods that
Shamir and one suggested and they got to
some a they they they didn't find the
guy but they found a lot of people that
were possible targets and then they did
a lot of good old-fashioned intelligence
and they they found the guy his name is
was already was 25 years old
it was living in a roommate apartment
even though he had 700,000 bitcoins so
and they decided they were going to take
his money no matter what like because
okay so remember you cannot get so you
can't seize bitcoins like you need the
private key they knew this guy would
never give them the private key if they
catch him so they had to actually catch
him in the act of transferring bitcoins
like using this account linked to Robert
so what they did is they ambushed him in
the library where he worked and they
wanted and waited until he opened his
laptop and inserted his password to his
account and then they jumped on him and
took his laptop and transferred the
bitcoins so this is kind of low-tech but
still impressive it's a way to do it so
they can be seized okay so so this is
the Silk Road you can see my MDMA okay
this is the transaction graph that they
created and they seized this they seized
the road and they seized the bitcoins
and they put it on their lake account
they're like we seized these bitcoins
they managed to get 144,000 out of I
think 700 thousand or something like we
said not everything he wasn't that
stupid so and okay they were safe so
they're probably the US government made
a lot of money from Bitcoin but there's
also a negative example of when this
didn't work is when Shyamalan won
themselves tried to find Satoshi
Nakamoto and they found an unrelated guy
like who security researcher guy and
this was very embarrassing because they
like raided his office and but he wasn't
the guy okay so sorry so I'm what what
was the problem with their method so the
the basic case
the basic idea that they had is that a
multiple inputs are the same entity but
there are actually mixing services
people who supply services that exactly
for this purpose like just transfer your
money into into and out of a lot of
accounts just to like make it harder to
track and I'll show you an example of
this and they also it becomes
computationally hard as graph grows
because there's like millions and
millions of nodes now it's not that easy
even if you have a linear time algorithm
for it it's it's hard hey okay so this
is the normal transaction or this also
get out like nothing then you have this
mix transaction so and now you in each
one of these if you open up its Scylla
another million transactions somewhere
so it's kind of hard to track
oh okay so that was the data science
part any questions about it every
transaction you can just like it's built
into the protocol you can have as many
addresses as you don't need an IP
address you just need your private key
and you can open as many addresses
public what happens today is like it's
not hey what happens is because there
are far more transactions because people
are buying bitcoins for investments now
so there are a lot more transactions
than then like the block the block size
is a one megabyte there's one every ten
minutes so there's a lot more
transactions and what can fit in a block
so what happens is they actually a
transactions with very high fees get in
so so you again can do a little bit like
double spending attacks like you can
transfer money to yourself with high
interest and money to someone else with
very low interest no fee and
but yes a little bit about Python
there's not much to tell really it's
very it's very simple to get to start
exploring
once you find like a normal pet there's
a few packages but I use the blockchain
package and block Explorer specifically
it's very easy to use you have to notice
a few things like if you look at an
output of a transaction it's actually
the public key but the input of your
transaction is not the public key but a
pointer to the previous location it is
the previous block and transaction in
which this person was an output publicly
so it's a little like messy but you can
like it's not hard to do and and that
you also use network X but it don't use
it if you're going to do large projects
on a on Python because it doesn't hold
up for not large numbers like use a user
local database if you're going to do
like a thing on the entire block change
okay so and this is an example of code
you'll have it in the presentation on
the website I think but so basically
what you see here is say I created this
entity graph I use Union fine to which I
didn't show here but it's a very simple
to write and I create I merge together
everything that has a multiple inputs
and created an entity graphs and again
integra and there it sits you see it's a
very short code even though it does
something kind of sophisticated so it's
very easy to use so the the package you
want to use is a blockchain package
which is natural if you want to do
things on blockchain but it took me a
while to find so okay any questions
about this
I couldn't find theoretical specs but I
saw that if you get to a million nodes
you're in trouble look in on the
internet on how to download the
blockchain you what you do is you
install a wallet and then you become
part like you the wallet it comes built
in with the all the source code in it
run and you run it and you it downloads
the blocks into your computer and you
have a wallet and a private kind of
public in how much this is the entire
blockchain right now it's something
around 250 300 gigabytes okay so okay so
this is a good question now there are
services that allow you to keep only
part of the blockchain like the last few
blocks on your phone but this is a
problem okay because we talked a little
bit about what you can do if you have a
lot of computational power so if if not
everybody keeps the blockchain on their
device
this increases the power of mining pools
in the network so every user that it
doesn't keep all of the blockchain on
their local device is actually a harming
the stability of the network so these
services are not so good for Bitcoin oh
also one thing that I wanted to add to
add a mining is very very expensive in
in electricity and around 0.1% of the
entire world
electricity take-up is Bitcoin mining
wait this is more than like a hundred
countries the like this is insane amount
of electricity so yeah and it's growing
research there's a lot of different
protocols a lot of different currencies
and they address different things like
so you have a theorem that lets you do
things smarter things instead in terms
of contracts and the block size is
bigger and there's more blocks per time
time period but this doesn't really
solve it there's a lot of protocols like
there's the specter protocol and they're
doing dog instance instead of least so
but it's not that the technology is not
there yet in terms of the blockchain any
one more question something about okay
yeah so a lot of banks in countries are
working on this also so ripple is not
doing something very original in the
sense the Bank of England is is working
on its own cryptocurrency but the thing
is that a Bitcoin like this is why
Krypton has like it it's not regulated
so anything that is like moderately
regulated is like a it's it's a
different thing it's a good thing I
think but it's a different thing than
what's a bit I think it's a very very
interesting interesting philosophical
question like no it's it's very it's
very interesting it's like the internet
basically it's something that completely
bypasses regulation it takes away money
from the government which is like the
the main power of the government is
money so this is like it's a
revolutionary thing in terms of concept
but the technology is not you
okay so thanks
[Applause]